in the woods did you get my note about  the no-go areas I cannot have people  wondering about middle of the night  these things always end up in a bloody  mess welcome slaughterhouse this is the  school pattern order at the top if the  bat in the middle cleansing eyes  watch where you're looking then down at  the bottom  what those weren't that's fortunately  I'm afraid mr. Prague will be unable to  teach today or ever again  he died here anyway there's something in  the woods what the top  that oh it's okay way big they strike  down now who wants to buy some drugs  they just ate half the aqua seat belts  everyone  stop worrying what they're gonna do eat  you alive  delicious  you